what's the millionaire morning routine a
lot of people ask these questions if you
look on youtube instagram tick tock
so-and-so's morning routine the five
things so-and-so does the moment he
wakes up they think that there's some
magic pill or some super five-step thing
that's gonna somehow get them to do the
work at the very end of this video i'll
give you my morning routine everything
that i do between when i wake up and
when i work we have to define what
productivity even means productivity is
getting more done per unit of time
people who move faster in life don't
actually move faster they get more done
per unit of time i had this guy reach
out to me he's like dude i got this
coach he's got me doing like morning
walks red lights on it and i do a cold
plunge and i do my gratitude journal
he's like by the time i'm done my
morning routine it's like 11 a.m and i
was like do you think you'd be more
productive if you just prospected for
three hours a day i was like yeah
probably and i was like doesn't sound
very productive though what's
interesting is that people approach the
problem of the fact that they're not
getting enough done per unit of time and
they think that i should add more things
that are not getting things done to
become more productive per unit of time
that doesn't make sense right why do
people not think that way because people
don't define the terms that they use but
if you define productivity as the amount
of work you do per unit of time probably
would stop doing a lot of the things
that you're doing that aren't working
when people give you their advice for
how to become productive think is this
adding things that are not work to my
calendar of the work that i'm doing how
much leverage am i getting from that
work so i can multiply even further at
the work that i do you order your tasks
in order of the leverage that they have
the definition of leverage is you get
more output per unit of input if i do a
little bit and i get a lot i have a lot
of leverage you simply have some things
that you get more money per period of
time and less money per period of time
that's it what are the tasks that get us
the most output for example i could make
sales calls that is going to be a
one-to-one input of like i do this
effort and i get sales out of it with
that same level of effort if i could go
recruit a salesperson which would take
me a finite period of time and then that
person replaces that my ongoing support
for that person is going to be two three
hours a week so i gain back 20 hours a
week of prospecting in exchange for two
to three hours a week plus money and so
the act of entrepreneurship is simply
consistently making these trades of what
can i buy my time back with even at the
point where you had an entire company
leading to one person and that person
talks to you if we were to try and think
of like the perfect morning routine we
should think about the reverse of that
which is what's the worst morning
routine how could i create a morning
routine that would make me the least
effective one i'll make it longest
humanly possible number two i'd have
lots of steps and processes involved so
that i could use up lots of mental
energy before i could even start working
number three is that i would become very
very reliant on that thing if i don't
get this one thing in then it means i
cannot work you have to make your bed in
order to become a millionaire the
problem with that is that we're
separating fact from psychology if i
make making my bed mean that i'm going
to do the things that i said i'm going
to do then it's super productive but
it's not the making the bed that's the
thing that's important it's the fact
that i'm committed to doing the things
that i said i'm going to do gurus will
get on this superstition around these
things that they do but not describe the
meaning that they've ascribed to the
thing oh i do this thing to establish
discipline then it's not the thing it's
the discipline in which case you could
replace the thing with any other thing
or you could just tell yourself your
discipline you don't need to prove it to
yourself the easiest way to disprove
something is to say let me find an
instance where this doesn't exist and i
still have the outcome that's how you
disprove something in like science if
there's a millionaire morning routine
then it would have to be the same thing
that all millionaires do you have to
wake up early i can tell you right now
plenty of millionaires don't wake up
early you have to have seven streams of
income all i have to do is find one
person who doesn't have seven streams of
income to show you that that's not true
do you have to do real estate in order
for millionaire no you have to be in
software you have to be in web three by
the way buddy doing 70 million a year
with janitorial services for big
buildings boring as [ __ ] the
anti-routine concept came from the fact
that i get asked by so many [ __ ]
people what my routine was because they
thought there was some magic pill of how
i got stuff done besides getting stuff
done that somehow is going to make them
confront the fact that they're not
working because they don't want to work
you don't need to create some magical
morning routine where you sing a flute
magical dance outside and sing in the
rain and the journals and all the other
[ __ ] like there's work to be done and
the question is how quickly can i begin
that work that's it the perfect routine
would be you wake up and you immediately
work because you've trained yourself to
be able to do it if you are one of these
people who has a 90-minute morning
routine before you start working try
waking up and walking straight over to
begin work don't even check your phone
most people spend most of their time
doing [ __ ] that doesn't matter and for
the people who are going to say isn't
the morning routine kind of like a
warm-up before a workout or actually
like need to prepare yourself before you
start working how long do you really
need to warm up your brain do you think
that your ability to warm up your brain
is trainable because if it's trainable
then your routine should shrink and your
number of hours of work should increase
it is people who are like i get more
done if i have a morning routine cool
see if you can just compress the morning
routine to take less time of the 10
things you do remove one see how you do
remove two see how you do the
fundamental equation of productivity how
much you do multiply by how much
leverage you have on the stuff you do if
we're defining those things as the
equation for productivity then the
perfect morning routine should be one
that maximizes the volume of work you do
and the leverage that you create from
the volume and so for me that looks like
waking up
having a cup of coffee and getting to
work and then ordering my day in the
order in which i have the highest
leverage activities to the lowest
leverage activities and if you enjoy
this stuff and you want to think about
how can i get more leverage for the work
i have then you should watch this 55
minute video which is the number one
video on my channel on leverage and
assessing opportunities